president Trump reportedly has a back-up
plan in case Trump care goes down in
flames he'll simply leave Obamacare in
place blame Democrats and then stump
from more Republican votes in Congress
to help him replace Obamacare yes really
according to CNN quote during an
hour-long meeting sources said Trump
chastised groups including Club for
Growth the Heritage Foundation Americans
for Prosperity Freedom Works and the Tea
Party Patriots for calling the House GOP
proposal Obamacare light warning the tea
party activists quote you are helping
the other side Trump said he will have a
football stadium events in states where
he won by 10 to 12 points and he's going
to dare people to vote against him a
source at the meeting said this is not a
good strategy here are three reasons
first you cannot keep selling people the
same smelly garbage Republicans said in
2010 they needed to be elected to
Congress to repeal Obamacare they failed
they said in 2012 they needed the Senate
to repeal Obamacare they failed they
said in 2014 they needed a bigger
majority in the house to repeal
Obamacare they failed they said in 2016
they need the White House to repeal
Obamacare
if they fail again do you really think
Republicans will keep going back to the
well on the same old promise when
Republicans could pass a one-line bill
repealing Obamacare now as a Lepanto
says it hot air at some point people get
wise to the scam second entitlements
don't fail they just grow who thinks
that Obamacare is going to fail for
those unmedicated II nope States will
continue to pile people on Medicaid
those people will continue to vote for
Democrats the entitlement program will
get bigger not smaller and when people
on Obama care plans can't obtain their
doctor who's to say they won't go to the
government for more money and bigger
subsidies rather than to crying the
evils of Obamacare we're already seeing
a spike in Obamacare's popularity now
their net there's talk of replacement do
we think that will stop when Republicans
vow to kill a law effecting a larger and
larger share of the health market no
entitlement program has ever gotten less
popular over time no matter how bankrupt
it is let's put it this way well Baba
Carol ready popular enough that
Republicans are afraid of killing it
outright give it another couple years
and Republicans will be talking about
how they want to preserve it the same
way they do with Social Security and
Medicare finally it's a midterm stupid
the president typically doesn't have the
upper hand in midterm battles
that's because is allah panda also
points out midterm elections are
naturally almost always referenda on the
president and his party
thus trump early think he can run
against obama in 2018 plus trump already
has control of congress who does he run
against that
perhaps you don't matter because they're
already in the minority so is it decent
strategy to let Obamacare stay and then
run against it now once you've made nuts
well not once your president promises
were made they should be kept the
biggest problem here is that Trump care
has less to do with the actuality of
repealing Obama care than the rhetoric
of it and talk is pretty cheap i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
all right tons to get to today I want to
talk a lot about this Steve King blow-up
that's happened because I think that
it's pretty clear that the media are
doing a hit job here and this is coming
from somebody who says that you know
when the media is right the media are
right when they are calling it
accurately they're calling it accurately
I'm not somebody who's knee-jerk when it
comes to the media it's always wrong the
media is always lying sometimes the
media is right sometimes the media is
wrong in this case I really think that
Steve King is getting railroaded a
little bit and some of that's his own
fault because he uses verbiage that is
that is really kind of stupid but some
of that a lot of it I think is is just
the media lying and so I want to talk
about that specifically in just a minute
but first we have to say thank you to
our advertisers are over at texture calm
so if you are somebody who's addicted to
information addicted to reading then you
need to go to texture comm and become a
subscriber the way that this works is
that you can get basically subscriptions
to tons and tons of magazine all their
back issues by subscribing to texture
comm they're a bunch to choose from I'm
just going to look at the list of
magazines that they have available it's
everything from Sports Illustrated to
National Geographic to Entertainment
Weekly to Vanity Fair to Better Homes
and Gardens to time I mean it's just
it's a it's a huge list I mean I'm
looking at pages and pages of magazines
here that you can subscribe to simply by
going to texture comm you go there $9.99
a month you got over 200 magazines if
you sign up right now at texture comm
slash bet you got a 14-day free trial so
you can see if you like it see if you
enjoy it I promise you well it's just
fantastic my wife and I both use it for
Reader's Digest which is one of the ways
we got a guest on a couple of weeks ago
the lady who came on and talked about
how she was caring for for terminal
babies I met her because I was reading
in Reader's Digest through texture comm
go to texture comm slash pen right now
is selected as one of Apple's top 2016
iPad apps start that free trial again
texture calm
/ been textured calm / been it's
entirely digital obviously and you're
never gonna run out of things to read
and if you are somebody who just can't
be away from information for any long
period of time like I am texture calm is
the best place to find information to
get in-depth analysis of the information
that you're reading about texture calm /
Ben make sure to add the / Ben so you
get that 14-day free trial and also so
that they know that we sent you okay so
I was going to start with Trump care
today and then there's a big controversy
that broke out this morning /
representative Steve King so full
disclosure I know representative King I
think representative King is from the
times I've met him he seems like a nice
fellow I don't think that representative
King is the brightest guy in the basket
I think that representative King tends
to boil everything down to to a little
bit too simplistic a version of reality
but here's what happens so Steve King
gets on Twitter over the weekend and he
tweets out will ders time Girt Wilders
over in over the Netherlands understands
that culture and demographics are our
destiny we can't restore our
civilization with somebody else's babies
okay there are two ways to read this
tweet I'll read it again slowly so
people understand will ders understands
that culture and demographics are our
destiny we can't restore our
civilization with somebody else's babies
there are two ways to read the tweet the
first way to read the tweet this is it
this is racism that if you bring in a
bunch of foreign babies they're going to
destroy the country there's no way to
assimilate them and that's because
they're black or they're they're from
Muslim countries or they're Arab or
whatever it is that's one way to read
the tweet that this is just out-and-out
racism you can't bring a bunch of
foreign babies and hope to maintain your
culture and that race is inherently
connected to culture that is that is way
one to read this tweet then there is way
to to read the tweet and that is that it
is badly phrase but not racist basically
King is saying that multiculturalism and
high levels of immigration from foreign
cultures cannot coexist and that is
utterly uncontroversial that is an
utterly uncontroversial proposition
Anglo Merkel has said exactly the same
thing in December 2015 she said
multiculturalism leads to parallel
societies and therefore remains a lie
fly or a sham
the challenge is immense we want and we
will reduce the number of refugees
noticeably is Merkel a white nationalist
as Merkel a white supremacist or a
racist I mean she wants to reduce the
number of refugees and it seems like
what she's saying here is that
multiculturalism
connected with high levels of
immigration from foreign culture creates
enclaves that are dangerous for any sort
of Western civilization that's
attempting to thrive is that racist
no that's reasonable David Cameron has
said the same thing in Great Britain
again Merkel and Germany has said the
exact same thing
naturally the media immediately jumps to
the first interpretation which is the
king is a racist that he's saying that
it doesn't matter if you have
assimilation working full-bore it
doesn't matter if you were checked month
like culturalism if you're from the
wrong country that means you're
inherently going to be a bad citizen of
the country so which one of these did
King mean did King mean that babies from
everywhere else are terrible right that
somebody else's babies we can trust our
civilization with somebody else's babies
does he mean by that that if somebody
else raises their babies not in
accordance with Western civilization you
can't restore your civilization or does
he mean any babies from elsewhere are
inherently bad and babies are terrible
because they have a different race so
fortunately we have some answers to this
so he goes on new day on CNN to clarify
this because this is something that does
require clarification right he goes on
new day with Chris Cuomo now Chris Cuomo
has the IQ of a block of wood as we've
mentioned before and so what has
happened here what has happened here is
that Chris Cuomo you'll watch watched on
this interview Chris Cuomo jumps in and
he immediately assumes the first right
that what what Steve King is actually
talking about is that babies from other
countries are terrible and evil and that
they can't be assimilated and Steve King
keeps saying no no no I'm not talking
about race I'm talking about culture if
you come to a culture if you if you come
from a culture that's different from the
United States is or Western
civilization's and you come in and you
don't assimilate in any way then that's
dangerous to the culture right you make
me angle a Merkel point they're talking
across purposes and you'll see that and
we'll talk about how the media have
really skewed this thing and in light
about it we need to be a country that's
pulled together on similar values that
makes us strong that's that's the exact
point I mean because it seemed like you
were doing the opposite like you were
trying to say someone else's babies
means you're either white or you're not
right and as you know that it's anathema
to what America is all about can we get
agreement on that well I want to out
here so actually if you go down the road
a few generations or maybe centuries
with the intermarriage I'd like to see
an America that's just so homogeneous
that if we look a lot the same from that
perspective I think there's been far too
much folk
on race especially in the last eight
years and I want to see that put behind
us and I want to be as bonded together I
gave a speech on this on Saturday and
half the Liberals got up and left the
room when I talked about because hatred
is the point Chris but hold on a second
congressman if you suggest that somebody
else's babies shouldn't be welcomed in a
country you seem inherently divisive
that's why I keep asking you what was
your intention with this and you keep to
seeing doubling down on it I mean you
said America has got lots of different
faces that's fine but you keep making
this point that this country needs to be
about white people raising their
birthrate and not bringing in other
people and then what what King says
there as the clip continues is
I never said white people need to raise
their birthrate he actually overtly
denies that right what he says is that
that's a lie he says quote I have never
said that I tell them to go back and
watch the tape right I mean this is he
said over amazing here is that so here's
here's where the media lies so in the
headline that you have seen this morning
undoubtedly the the headline that you've
seen this morning is King quote I'd like
to see an America that's just so
homogeneous that we look a lot the same
if you just see that headline you would
assume immediately that what Steve King
is talking about is that he just wants
to see lots of white babies he wants a
racially homogeneous America with lots
of white babies that's the implication
of that headline but the first half of
the sentence is if you go down the road
a few generations and maybe centuries
with the intermarriage I'd like to see
in America this just so homogeneous that
we look a lot the same okay let me
explain something as somebody who's been
labeled to cook by the alt-right as I
mean who hates the outright who despises
racism who thinks racism is disgusting
if I thought Steve King was being racist
here if I thought that what he was
actually talking about was the first
interpretation of his tweet not the
second interpretation I'd be the first
person calling for his censure on the
floor of the house I'd be calling for
his constituents to dump him at the
nearest bus stop okay this idea that you
know I'm looking to defend Steve King
for racist comments is just silly but
what's amazing here is again the first
half of the sentence is that he wants to
see more intermarriage not less he wants
to see all the races intermingle last I
checked that's not a white supremacist
position it's not a white nationalist
position it's not a position that
suggests that race and ethnicity are
inherently connected with culture right
what he's saying he's saying precisely
the opposite actually it's awkward it's
stupid the way he's doing it it's silly
the way that he's phrasing it but that's
not what he's saying he's not saying I
just want a bunch of white people he
said quote if you go down the road a few
generations or maybe centuries with the
intermarriage I'd like to see in America
that's just so homogeneous we look a lot
the same the reason I mentioned the
alt-right here is because what the
alt-right has called people like me
people who actually like immigration I
think immigration is a good thing when
combined with assimilation I want more
immigration when combined with
assimilation you're looking at somebody
right now or listening to somebody right
now who said I would trade 50 million
people from abroad who share America's
values for people who live in the United
States and don't appreciate America's
values I don't care where you're born I
don't care what race you are I think
that that's actually sort of what King
is saying here and that and the media is
out to jump on him because they're
suggesting that what he really means is
that black babies are bad as opposed to
if we bring in people from a bunch of
foreign cultures and don't assimilate
them those babies are not going to make
American culture better because they're
not gonna be assimilated in fact here's
listen listen to King talk a little bit
more because I wanna I want to show you
what he's actually saying if you suggest
that somebody else's babies shouldn't be
welcome in a country you seem inherently
divisive that's why I keep asking you
what was your intention with this and
you keep to seeing doubling down on it I
mean you said America has got lots of
different faces that's fine
but you keep making this point that this
country needs to be about white people
raising their birth rate and not
bringing in other people that's exactly
what America is not but Chris I never
have made that point I've never said
that I've been a characterized as saying
that I've had the blogs out there say I
said that but I tell them go back and
watch the tape listen to it just listen
to the language our language is precise
that's not out there but I did defend
Western civilization that started this
last summer at the Republican National
Convention and when I said Western
civilization that launched people that
are opposed to Western civilization
that's a big problem if we have an
element of Americans here and that's a
big element that reject Western
civilization then what have we if this
is an effort on the left I think to
break down the American civilization in
the American culture and turn it into
something entirely different
I'm a champion for westerns
civilization and yes our English
language is a big part of it it's a
carrier of freedom wherever the English
language has gone globally freedom went
with it and science technology has
always lifted up the standard of living
on average of everybody on the planet so
I want more of that not less and there
are civilizations that produce very
little if any this Western civilization
still is a superior civilization and we
want to share it with everybody okay he
keeps saying civilization and culture
you know civilization and culture
civilization and culture and coamo just
keeps going back to race because Cuomo
wants to get him on the race point but
that's not what King is saying and so
when you read the headlines today and
when you see people immediately jumping
to Steve King as a racist or so what
Steve King said here anyway is racist
just do yourself a favor and do your own
research on this stuff because the fact
is and listen to what they're actually
saying because the headlines
do not convey what exactly was going on
in this case and it's very frustrating
because I've been in arguments this
morning on Twitter with people and I
keep just quoting King right just keep
saying okay here's what he actually said
here's the actual text of what he said
here's what he hears what he tweeted
here's what he said here's what he meant
and everybody just keeps going - but
that's not what they want to believe
everybody just keeps doubling down on
what they want to believe what's the
narrative they want to embrace what's
the convenient narrative to embrace and
there's some virtually signalling I
think going on from some people on the
right who are looking to just
disassociate with anybody who says
anything mildly controversial and who
are looking to prove to everybody
they're not racist by throwing this guy
under the bus for saying something that
really actually is not racist what he's
saying right now is not actually racist
he keeps denying that it's racist and he
keeps saying again when I keep going
back to this point when I'm called the
okay the term what that means
is that I want to see the races mixed
right that I want to see the races mixed
because I'm a terrible person it's
according to white supremacists if I
didn't support Trump sufficiently it's
because I'm a kook who wants my wife to
have sex with a black person said oh how
black babies in between it about it by
mile oh eun-ah police right that's that
that's dumb and it's demonstrative of
the fact that I am a okay there's
nothing more caucus than what just got
said there by Steve King with regards
Ian's remeasured
okay if you think that the white
supremacists are into that that's just
it's just not true so I think that it's
worthwhile - bunking this kind of stuff
because you know we're we attempt to be
fair-minded and objective and honest as
we can be here on the program in line
with conservative principles and I'm not
just
bend over backwards and say that the guy
said something racist when we can all
look at the tape ourselves and determine
whether who's lying here is a king or is
the media who are lying about him okay
well before I get to Trump carrots
there's a lot to talk about there we
have to say thank you to our friends
over at distilled so if you are looking
for a really nice pair of jeans if you
are looking for a pair of jeans that is
going to last you a long time high
quality looking for something under a
hundred bucks because a solid pair of
jeans will cost you 100 bucks at a
retail outlet you need to go to DST LD
com DST LD calm right now and check it
out I own a pair of DST LD jeans in fact
I think I own a couple and they are
really nice I wear them all the time
I love learned jeans and DST dealt DST
LD distilled jeans are the highest
quality there is if you go over to DST
LD calm right now and you use slash been
DST LD calm slash been then you do get a
ten percent discount so you can go over
there and check it out right now
distilled calm you get that ten percent
off your first pair off your first pair
of DST LD calm slash been and use the
slash pen not only for the discount and
also they know that we sent ya and that
means that they will be more likely to
continue advertising which is great for
the program and great for you so DST LD
calm slash Ben thank you to to our
sponsors okay so now why don't talk a
little bit out the myths and the facts
surrounding Trump care because this
rollout continues amidst all of the
chaos amidst all of the hubbub z-- the
the fact is that the the Trump care
rollout continues apace and the
Democrats continue to lie about it and
when I say Democrats I mean the
quote-unquote conservative columnist at
the New York Times to say David Brooks
is the in-house conservative columnist
at the New York Times and he says that
Trump care is just a boondoggle for the
rich he theory was on NBC News this
again the conservative at the New York
Times well here's what I don't get about
what's going on this week we just had
2016 an election about the working class
election where we learned that a lot of
people are out of the job market
the social fabric is framed and so the
lesson is lesson pay attention help
these people so the Republican Party
could help these people with
market-based mechanisms which I support
do they do that now they have huge tax
cuts for the
which tact this investment income tax
credit only those two people above 250
and that has been state when all the
plans that they've come up with and
thrown around and meanwhile they're
thrown 8 10 15 million people off the
rolls so it's a declaring war on their
own voters and then there's a wing of
the party that's saying no that's too
much
we need to totally decimate them so the
Republican Party is to figure out are we
gonna help our voters or are we still
the party that you know we're still
gonna be the party of the rich well I
hate this crap I hate it and I will
explain how much I hate it in just a
second but for that you're gonna have to
go over to the Daily wire calm right now
daily wire calm become a subscriber $8 a
month will get you a subscription to
daily wire.com plus if you subscribe
annually we still have a special offer
for you got a free DVD copy of the
arroyo great film set on the southern
border from our own jeremy boring
top-notch filmmaking to western and set
on the southern border about a rancher
trying to resist the drug cartels using
his land as a thoroughfare for illegal
immigration and drugs check it out daily
wired.com to become a subscriber and if
you want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud and give us a
listen and make sure that you rate us on
iTunes as well we always appreciate that
we are the number one conservative
podcast in the United States
[Music]
you